t
vite et plus fort 90 fois par minute mon
coeur bat pour la musique et les
leproux à la minute pour 1 100 et 1 ou
te promets jouer du tabac qui qu'a dit
la cour
e
de mélodies hantait la marge tchatche un
bémol
araud à cheval sur le tempo jeu
voyager dans la musique moi je dis c'est
pas chic là pas besoin de papier a4
laisser voter
à
m
ap rouler avec tout beau tout ça mais
couleurs primaires je pense de mons où
les tombeaux pour régler les longs du
maire
pour aller un contrôle je tends perdit
dans le temps et j'y rencontre avec de
sensations et
emporté par la fougue et une vague des
triolets ou le boul gérer bull en plein
coeur d'une et bourré
voyager dans la musique que moi je dis
c'est pas chic là pas besoin de papier
a4 laisser porter
à
oui
mais
l'elysée
les données révélées
et
et dès que je refais surface je suis
appelé par le vent qui m'apprennent sur
les traces d'un vieux rails hamon
j'ai trouvé dans lance et un blanc delic
besoin de vous un vrai manque un peu de
mordant
le zoo
tmusique qui se croisent au beau milieu
des coins ça fait des samba issoise et
des valses à coeur
voyager dans la musique comme moi je dis
c'est fantastique là pas besoin de
papier a4 laisser porter
pas
et
m
merci rita macedo vers si françoise
chapuis cette année